let's start at the beginning how did you
both come into involvement with the
project so let's start with you ceciling
yeah Nina had done her lecture and
actually it's interesting because uh
this had always been something that was
percolating in her mind and something
that she had noticed and since she was
making her films but then with the me
too movement and specifically with the
trial of Harvey Weinstein when he was
you know because he was accused and that
was I think October 2017. she wrote an
article in filmmaker magazine about it
connecting that and the metoo movement
to the objectification of women in
cinema and this article went viral and
it became actually the most read article
at filmmaker in that entire year
and so she had a lecture that she was
doing for her students about the
objectification of women in cinema and
it was uh 10 to 15 film clips
and so
um she started to to take that around
people were asking her to come she went
to Sundance and Rotterdam and around the
world but this lecture just kind of one
at a time you know lecturing to 50
people and so people started coming up
to her and saying you should make this
into a film
and so I came on board when she had been
kind of working with the footage and
trying to figure out how to turn it into
a film and coming in and saying you know
really looking at it and saying I think
as a film we shouldn't do it
chronologically we should do it
thematically I think we should look at
the triangle and really look at you know
for me as an editor I was thinking about
subjectivity
um we're seeing what we're seeing in the
film but how is it making us feel can we
can we explore how it makes women feel
to watch this and you know it's very
bold really to have a psychoanalyst in
the film and you know this just became a
long and really interesting year-long
conversation about what
um you know what to show and and who we
wanted to speak to this
and what about you Sharon I came to the
film because of a wonderful woman who's
sitting here summer Yang was the
producer of the film one of the
producers and she brought me to the film
she introduced me to Nina who never
worked with a composer before
so it was a new experience for her it
was also something that scared her a
little bit as Cecily knows but
um
it was also extremely challenging
musically because
first because she tempted the whole
thing meaning putting temp music in by
Bernard Herman's vertigo which is you
know it's uh definitely a legend I mean
Bernard Herman's one of you know film
music most celebrated composers
um and when I when I heard it I said
um this is amazing but you gotta give me
an orchestra which you did but this is
how I came to the film and when I saw
the film you know as as a woman and as a
mom for an 11 years old the scenes in
this film that were extremely hard for
me to look at
extremely hard to like feel if I was in
this position and
we all have been through some
experiences uh that have not been
Pleasant especially as a woman composer
you know it's it was it was uh something
that I really wanted to to dig in and to
do and be a part of something that might
lead to a more serious conversation and
might lead to some kind of a
of a change in the industry and it's
always
um
really good to be something to be a part
of something that actually can make a
difference I was thinking about how
emotionally involved this had to be and
you just kind of touched on that a
little bit some things in this movie are
so difficult to acknowledge and to
realize that we live with
how was it for you talk about the
process of really engaging those
emotions and needing to relive them and
channel them over and over as you
created this
yeah it was definitely uh this film was
a challenge on so many levels uh
technically emotionally it was it was
and and thanks to I'm I'm really
appreciative of Nina for giving me the
time to do it because
sometimes I get to score films in two
weeks and it's just crazy and but you
can't you have to I mean you can but
it's here you really I had to really dig
in
and especially because Nina has never
worked with a composer before it was a
new experience for her I kind of walked
her through the process
so I told Nina just let me do the first
scene and then we'll talk and after I
score the first scene which is about
four minutes or so she called me she
said yes yes yes that's exactly what I
wanted and from that it was a much
um easier process
but
first she's very meticulous which I like
you know because I find that when I
score a film the director's notes
usually make my music better so I'm very
open to that but emotionally how do you
bring about all these
very dark emotions as a woman
without being over dramatic and that was
I think
the challenging part and there were a
few points when I was doing a bit more
and she's like no no don't give me Star
Wars what I want is this subtle
um
um nuances of the film and you know
after I did the first 20 minutes or so I
told after the first 20 minutes
everything is established and everything
will be a smooth sailing from that and
which is exactly what happened but
um like the scene
on the plane when she is like hand-tied
and I was like
it was really hard for me to see it
because you're like she's so hopeless
I'm helpless I'm sorry not hopeless
maybe hopeless as well but it's like you
know I think we need to talk about these
issues and we need to address them
and I know that not everybody is going
to like this film because you know kind
of puts a mirror on
Hollywood and I'm part of Hollywood and
you're part of Hollywood and I love
Hollywood but these are things that we
need to talk about I was wondering if
as accomplished artists and filmmakers
yourselves
if
examining this film really taking in its
meaning
if that's changed your art
has that changed the way that you feel
about your work in some way and perhaps
how you approached maybe this project or
or maybe even some in the future
you know even though I knew about this
stuff you know it's amazing when you're
watching a beautiful film or you're
involved in making a film what you can
kind of think well I feel a little
uncomfortable about this but maybe it's
okay maybe it's just me maybe I'm the
only one who feels alienated or a little
bit strange
um and uh it's awkward as an editor
definitely to see shots and you kind of
say okay why are we showing this what
are we doing here and
um
as I've
now I have the option to choose all my
own work you know that wasn't always the
case that I had every job opportunity
but now I can I can choose and I can say
I don't you know I don't want to do
something where I feel like this is
going to be the default
and we're just going to default to this
I think as a filmmaker myself it also
made me think
about that incredibly complicated
subject of why do I choose what I choose
why aesthetically am I using this
instead of that and I'm looking forward
to other creators seeing it and thinking
that as well Cecily I'd like for you to
just close this out by giving everyone
watching
the impression or or that I that you
hope they leave with after watching this
important and thoughtful film
all right I wish I could open up your
heads and place the thought inside I
know I can't but um I really think
there's a strong connection between how
we see ourselves how women are portrayed
in films and how they're thought of in
society now when we were making this uh
Roe v Wade was not overturned
um I have to say you know recent
articles you know Jamel Bowie has
written about this or in the new
Republic how women cannot be treated as
objects you know women are not things
women should have agency women's bodies
belong to themselves and that these
attitudes that they do not belong to
women and that women are you know
property or decisions need to be made
for them we need to really look at our
culture and see where some of this might
have come in on a subconscious level and
I think there's a connection here and I
just I like to plant that idea that this
is something that goes beyond film and
as filmmakers
especially here in Hollywood to think
about what we're putting out in the
world and how that is affecting the
world that we live in for ourselves and
for our children
and if I could add
I think it's about
when you do something when you
create a film and you have scenes like
that what if it was your daughter right
what if it was your sister your mother
my husband is here and you know he
watched it and you know what if it was
her daughter she's 11 she's now starting
to be a young woman it's very scary I
think it's just a matter of perception
and a matter of just thinking a little
bit deeper and not just take everything
for granted because that's the way it's
been it has been until now okay that's
the way it has been until now and as
Nina says she's not a sex police sex is
part of our Lives you know it's not like
there's no sex in films but there's
maybe a different way
when scenes like that are part of a
project maybe to think twice before they
are shot in the same way that it always
has been shot and maybe give a bit more
respect to to not only the women on the
set but also the men on the set you know
so because you know for an actor I'm
thinking for an actor
if both of them need to be naked in a
scene that's not comfortable for a man
as well right but if there's mutual
respect and respect of the whole crew
and the director and the producer I
think there's there are ways to make it
a bit more
um
comfortable for them that it sends the
right message out for the next
Generation seen films like they have
been until now and thinking that this is
reality and it's not right well and in
these times I think the thought is
valued more than ever perhaps and so
thank you to both of you for being a
part of something that is going to be so
important and is so important in that
exact line so thank you everybody and
you can find more incredibly important
and interesting information over at
brainwashedmovie.com please do share
about this movie on social media it's at
brainwashed movie on both Instagram and
Facebook thank you so much for being
here tonight my name is gray Drake and
thank you again to Sharon Farber and
Cecily Rhett thank you thanks for having
us thanks everyone
[Applause]